bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi croissance et
activités le projet de loi mc rouge
propose dans quelques instants de revoir
les débats et le vote ce matin sur un
amendement qui nous concerne tous un
amendement sur les moteurs de recherche
un amendement déposé par la présidente
centriste de la commission de la culture
catherine morin desailly il a été adopté
à l'unanimité
il propose de garantir le principe de
neutralité d'internet et de lutter
contre l'abus de position dominante de
certains moteurs de recherche
un amendement qui intervient dans un
contexte où la commission européenne
accuse google justement de position
dominante et de mettre en exergue ses
propres liens sur sa page voilà pour le
contexte tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle pour les débats et le vote
sur cet amendement
nous passons un article additionnel avec
995 rectifié bis
madame morin desailly vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président on a
beaucoup parlé du déploiement des
réseaux est essentielle au développement
de notre économie
aujourd'hui je souhaite qu'on parle un
petit peu d des usagers de la maîtrise
de l'écosystème tels que il fait vivre
désormais toute notre économie
les craintes face au pouvoir de monopole
des géants de l'internet américain ne
cesse de croître en france et en europe
pas seulement français en europe mais
également aux états unis où il ya
quelques semaines la très officielle est
fait ici qui est l'autorité de
régulation a mis en exergue les parties
qu'anti concurrentiel du moteur de
recherche google
après une enquête qui d'ailleurs a été
enterré en 2013 des collègues sénateurs
américains sont en train d'enquêter là
dessus en novembre dernier le parlement
européen avait adopté une résolution
pour la défense des droits des
consommateurs sur le marché numérique
qui appelé la commission européenne à
envisager des propositions afin de mieux
séparer les moteurs de recherche
d'autres services appartenant à ces
mêmes groupes cette préoccupation
concernant les moteurs de recherche
s'explique tout simplement par le fait
qu'ils sont la principale porte d'entrée
à internet
ce sont des acteurs structurants ce sont
des acteurs qui constituent des
infrastructures incontournable désormais
or le comportement de ces acteurs
structurants porte parfois atteinte au
pluralisme des idées des opinions nuit à
l'innovation et entrave la liberté
d'entreprendre et de commercer la
question de la loyauté de ses opérateurs
à la à l'égard des acteurs français et
européens est essentielle comme l'a
relevé le conseil d'état dans son étude
annuelle 2014 le numérique et les droits
fondamentaux
le projet de loi qui nous intéresse pour
la croissance d'activité l'égalité des
chances économiques qui vise justement à
établir une concurrence saine sur
plusieurs marchés susceptible de libérer
l'activité économique et de créer de
l'emploi ne peut laisser de côté le
secteur du numérique qui constitue un
des principaux relais de croissance
économique à venir le numérique ce n'est
pas une seule industrie c'est
aujourd'hui et demain
toutes les industries c'est la
préoccupation du scénar exprimé en
particulier ces dernières ces derniers
mois à travers un rapport d'une mission
commune d'information sur le nouveau
rôle et la nouvelle stratégie pour
l'union européenne dans la gouvernance
de l'internet qui dit que l'europe ne
peut rester une colonie du monde
numérique et qu'il est plus que temps
que nos sociétés de plus en plus
dépendante à l'internet réagissent il
est donc urgent de se donner les moyens
d'encadrer les pratiques de ses moteurs
de recherche compte tenu des
conséquences néfastes et avérée
qu'occasionne certaines de leurs
pratiques pour l'innovation pour nos
entreprises pour les consommateurs bien
sûr cet objectif passe par la mise en
place d'une régulation ex ante et le
classement des résultats par un moteur
de recherche conditionne très largement
la visibilité effective d'une
information sur internet et partant
l'attention que lui porte
l'internaute or ce dernier a tendance à
accorder une confiance abusive dans les
résultats des algorithmes perçu comme
objectif est infaillible
notamment car il ne dispose d'aucune
information contenue et madame morin
desailly et que du fait conclure
d'exclusivité
il n'a parfois pas d'autre choix que de
se référer aux résultats d'un unique
moteur c'est un amendement important
monsieur le président d'accor oui en
août par le truchement du paramétrage de
son algorithme et dans madame morin
desailly je ne peux pas vous laisser
continuer je n'ai conclure en deux mots
générales d'utilisation à moteur de
recherche peut refuser de référence et
ou de classer ou bien de des référés
déréférencer ou déclassés tout site
internet
tout cela pour dire que le présent
amendement vise justement à préserver la
liberté d'entreprendre des opérateurs
économiques français en existence
numérique qui bien sûr en découlent et
confie un rôle de régulation et de
contrôle à l'autorité idoine pied la
remercie alors sur cet amendement a été
déposé un sous-amendement 1792 par
monsieur assouline
vous avez la parole en trois minutes oui
oui non très rapidement parce que il y
aura d'autres interventions mais c'est
un sujet qu'à la commission culture nous
partageons depuis longtemps et qui est
cette grande difficulté avec l'as vence
et maintenant le monopole qu'on
quasiment acquis d des entreprises aussi
verticale que google de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait des régulations notamment
qui contreviennent pas au droit européen
auquel nous sommes soumis même si très
souvent nous avons tel ou tel désaccord
avec lui et donc cet amant bien on vient
manifester cette volonté politique
unanime notamment dans le domaine
culturel dans le domaine de
l'information parce que on voit à quelle
abus
tout cela conduit compris à aller
jusqu'à capter une grande partie de ce
qu'est la création française et ses
droits j'ai voulu le sous-amendé pour
renforcer cette volonté puisqu'il s'agit
de dire pour madame morin desailly qu'il
faut au moins trois moteurs de recherche
proposé qu'il y en ait au moins un
c'est ma précision dont le siège social
soit en france ce qui permet de d'aller
dans le sens et de préciser cette
volonté de encourager la
les entreprises françaises et notamment
ceux qui en france se positionne sur ce
créneau dont je sais rien de
contradictoire
je veux juste dire tout de même que j'ai
conscience complètement que tant dans
l'amendement de madame morin desailly
que dans mon sous amendement il y a
surtout une volonté politique parce
qu'en terme de droit européen voire même
de droit constitutionnel celui-ci sais
c'est pas sûr que ça tienne complètement
mais je tiens à dire que cette
manifestation et cette volonté politique
doit être affirmé ici c'est pour cela
que je m'inscris dont l'amendement de
madame morano série mais la réalité
c'est que nous cherchons parce que nous
avons ce retard est parce qu elle ce
monopole sans arrêt à réguler avec des
barrières qui tombe devant leur
puissance
or l'europe depuis bientôt dix ans
aurait dû s'engager dans le fait de
mettre un vrai concurrent face et si
tous les états européens
c'est tous les savoir faire les
scientifiques la masse potentiel de
l'europe dans le domaine du numérique où
on pourrait les premiers si on savait
s'unir
mettez en phase de google un concurrent
peut-être que google n'aurait pas ce
monopole donc il faut réguler mais il
faut surtout maintenant accélérer le
fait qu'au niveau européen
lille y ait de la mise en commun et je
pense que pour ce que sera le numérique
dans dix ans si on le fait maintenant
peut-être qu'on sera devant google
peut-être qu'on sera devant tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui ont ce monopole en ce
qui concerne le numérique au plan
international on n'y a pas que la
régulation
je suis d'accord qu'on le fasse mais y
aura donc lieu à solives vraiment ray au
niveau économique pour qu'ils aient une
vraie concurrence en face ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui très bien avec
les l'avis de la commission madame sur
le sous-amendement la commission
spéciale n'a pas pu l'examiner
puisqu'ils viennent
être via nous être distribués comme ça
au pied levé si je peux employer cette
expression un peu un peu triviale
il nous semble que la conformité avec le
droit européen de la concurrence est
très incertain monsieur assouline l'a
dit en arguant du fait que certes
c'était vraisemblablement le cas mais
que c'était également 4 celui de madame
morin desailly ce qui est peut-être un
peu moins sûr et si tel est le cas nous
pensons que c'est pas la peine d'en
rajouter en incertitude par rapport au
droit européen de la concurrence et donc
une demande de retrait et sinon ce sera
un avis défavorable et celui le 995 donc
cet amendement traits d'un nouveau sujet
qui ne figuraient pas dans le texte à ce
stade ça a été dit celui des moteurs de
recherche et de la façon dont il traite
et livrent l'information à leurs
utilisateurs
nous savons tous qu'un de ses moteurs de
recherche exerce une position dominante
sur le marché français notamment transit
en effet par lui la très grande majorité
des demandes de recherche formulées par
les internautes
or cet éditeur de services est
régulièrement mis en cause pour un
traitement biaisé entre guillemets des
informations qui le conduirait ne pas
faire preuve d'une totale objectivité
dans les résultats qui fournit à ses
utilisateurs en mettant d'abord en avant
ce soit ses propres services soit des
opérateurs qu'il a comme clients il en
résultera ainsi une certaine tromperie
de l'usagé qui pensent que les résultats
de la recherche sont parfaitement
objectif rationnel alors que le moteur
privilégient certains au détriment
d'autres selon son seul intérêt il en
résulte également une mise à liqueur à
l'écart des acteurs de l'internet qui ne
rentrent pas dans le jeu du moteur
dominant et se trouvent des classes et
dans les résultats de recherche
ce qui signifie pour eux une mort
économique à plus ou moins long terme
pour y faire face le présent amendement
propose de respecter des obligations de
transparence de loyauté et de non
discrimination dans le fonctionnement de
tout moteur de recherche dominant est
assorti cette obligation de sanctions
pécuniaires
sur le principe nous sommes tout à fait
favorable à cet amendement
cependant il y avait des interrogations
sur son applicabilité puisqu'il est
assez intrusive dans le fonctionnement
du moteur dominant visé est peut-être
pourrait brouiller la lisibilité de ses
résultats par les internautes est en
trop et en outre gelé déjà évoqué nous
avons du mal apprécié la robuste et sur
hoëdic de l'amendement au regard
notamment du principe de liberté de
commerce
c'est pourquoi la commission spéciale
coin quoique bienveillante sur le
principe de l'amendement s'en est tenu
un avis de sagesse très bien monsieur le
billet oui je préside dangereux j'aurais
sur ces deux amendements une demande de
retrait pourquoi je pense que si vous ne
les retire et pas ils seront votés de
toute façon puisque cela c'est
satisfaisant de s'exprimer face à google
et donc vous n'allez pas réussir à
réprimer cet enthousiasme collectif
maintenant que je me suis habitué à vous
donc donc voilà mais donc je veux
néanmoins plaidé pour expliquer pourquoi
je pense que le retrait est une
meilleure formule d'abord il s'est en
effet passé hier quelque chose
la commission européenne a pris ses
pleines responsabilités il faut lui
reconnaître après la saisine et c'est
dur qui a commencé en 2010 vous avez
raison madame la sénatrice
c'est vrai madame la présente je vous
reconnais ce point nous avons
constamment poussé à tous les niveaux
pour que cette décision soit prise mais
elle est importante
nous avons accompagné les dix huit
opérateurs français qui ont mené cette
action contre google et donc il hier la
commission a trouvé suite aux
investigations
une base pour véritablement précisément
contraindre google a clarifié s'est
orientée clarifier véritablement ses
engagements et a annoncé avoir notifié à
google des griefs sur le comparateur de
prix alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que ils se sont aperçus ils
ont pu montrer que l'algorithme avait
favorisé le comparative le comparateur
de prix google
indépendamment de ces performances que
ça l'avait favorisé et que ce faisant et
que ce faisant ça avait conduit à
améliorer les performances du
comparateur de prix et donc l
discriminés par rapport aux autres
secteurs ce qui est un point important
il ya en même temps les actions qui sont
conduites sur android et donc la
plateforme mobile
et là c'est une procédure formelle qui a
été ouverte donc la commission
européenne prend ses responsabilités la
commissaire veste agger mène cette
action et le gouvernement a constamment
pris ses responsabilités pour pousser la
commission en ce sens mans dans tous les
contacts que j'ai eus avec la
commissaire joly à chaque fois rappelé
nous avons été très exigeant avec le
commissaire almunia à la fin de son
précédent mandat pour qu'il n'y ait pas
un compromis hâtif qui soit trouvé avec
les opérateurs sans test de marché ce
qui avait été un moment
la proposition qui était fait et donc
nous continuons à avancer
pourquoi parce que le sujet et c'est
finalement ce pourquoi essentiellement
je vais aller dans les détails mais moi
je vous incite au retrait sur cet
amendement et vous le savez vous savez
madame la prison c'est un sujet européen
le bon niveau à la fois en termes de
compétences et de taille critique
ça n'est pas le niveau national ce n'est
pas le niveau national et vous l'avez
vous même écrit dans votre rapport en
mars 2013
je vous cite l'échelon national n'est
assurément pas l'échelon pertinent pour
appréhender la révolution numérique
seule l'union européenne à la masse
critique pour peser dans le cyberespace
et c'est vrai parce que la bonne
compétence par rapport aux problèmes que
vous voulez attraper c'est la commission
européenne c'est d'ailleurs sa
compétence exclusive en fait la deuxième
chose c'est que c'est le bon niveau on
peut s'amuser à envoyer des signaux très
forts face à google
on le fait mais prendre des textes comme
on l'avait voulu un moment le fer avec
la taxe google c'est s'exposer à des
mesures parfois de représailles
unilatérale sur des acteurs français et
s'est créé des billets dans l'avancée
européenne faut continuer ce travail
pour convaincre les autres on va dans
quelques semaines faire proposer un
texte au delà des engagements déjà pris
par nos chefs d'état et de gouvernement
une stratégie numérique franco-allemande
pour que début mai la commission
européenne qui prendra sa stratégie
numérique puisse être éclairée par le
tandem franco allemand
c'est la bonne méthode pour avancer ses
lames et c'est la seule méthode efficace
parce que aussi pour ces acteurs qui
sont devenus des plateformes mondiale et
d'ailleurs dont les pays d'origine se
pose aujourd'hui la même question que
les etats-unis se se poser il ya plus
d'un siècle sur standard doyle qui est
celui du démantèlement
ces pays ont créé des champions
dont les marchés critiques ne sont pas
là la taille d'un état c'est le marché
européen qui est le bon marché si on
veut pardon de cette expression mais
ferme à la google
donc je pense que l'instrument que vous
utilisez le point d'entrée qui est le
vôtre est largement un parfait et nous
déstabiliserait dans cette action
groupée constamment apporté au niveau
européen à travers nos acteurs que nous
défendons et avec lesquels nous poussons
à travers ce dialogue avec la commission
européenne et la stratégie numérique
ensuite vous proposé d'encadrer le
comportement des moteurs de recherche en
mettant un régime d'obligations de
sanctions bon je vais là quand même
rentrer dans le détail parce que je sais
que vous êtes sensible à la fabrique du
droit
j'ai aussi beaucoup appris depuis dix
jours et donc et c'est pas fini
et donc d'abord pour qualifier
juridiquement un effet structurant sur
l'économie qui entraînerait l'opposition
l'imposition d'une obligation on peut se
rattacher au droit de la concurrence
mais dans ce cas nous sommes ramenés au
régime actuel et on pourra y revenir
dans le débat
le droit sectoriels comme celui des
télécoms il recourt quant à lui à des
analyses exhaustives des marchés en
cause avant d'imposer des remèdes
parce qu'il repose sur la base du droit
européen et donc je pense que par la
qualification que vous prenez de l'effet
structurant sur l'économie vous ne
pouvez reprendre une simple notion de
droit de la concurrence parce que vous
êtes sur le secteur des collègues des
télécoms et donc on devra aller plus
loin ensuite il ya quatre types
d'obligations
il semble que la première elle est à la
fois peu praticable et sans doute
disproportionnés
c'est précisément celle qui consisterait
en quelque sorte a demandé à renault
d'afficher sur son pare brise le fait
qu'il est aussi possible d'acheter une
peugeot et une fiat en quelque sorte sur
le moteur de recherche et le biais sur
le comparateur de prix c'est exactement
ce que la commission vient de pointer en
demandant une obligation ex ante est tel
que vous le le demande tel que vous le
proposait je pense que vous allez à la
fois trop loin et en même temps ce sera
peu praticables il s'agit d'une
obligation qui serait vraisemblablement
jugé inconstitutionnel car constituant
une atteinte disproportionnée à la
liberté d'entreprendre la seconde
obligations elle porte sur l'information
du conte du consommateur et ça je vous
souhaite
bien sûr la deuxième obligation je
reviendrai l'information du consommateur
je pense là qu'on peut faire beaucoup et
d'ailleurs c'est un de nos leviers
d'action mais elle ne peut néanmoins pas
faire l'objet du type de sanctions que
vous prévoyez et là dessus je reviendrai
très précisément et la troisième
obligations ensuite que vous proposez
elle est au coeur de la procédure en
cours devant la commission européenne
qui concerne google car c'est en read
elle est en réalité déjà couvertes par
le droit de la concurrence qu'il soit
national ou européen
d'ailleurs il vous aura pas échappé que
la procédure européenne que j'évoquais
elle vient donc de franchir cette
nouvelle étape importante que nous
réclamions par la notification des
griefs qui s'est fait hier et elle porte
sur les conditions de traitement de ses
propres services dans les résultats
affichés par son moteur de recherche et
donc l'ouverture d'une phase
contentieuse va permettre d'avancer ça
je pense que c'est un point important je
déplore comme vous les délais mais c'est
un outil significatif est la quatrième
obligations il me semble qu'elle confond
quant à elles deux sujets le moteur de
recherche
il fait de fournir aussi des systèmes
logiciels pour les terminaux parce que
c'est le cas de google avec android mais
alors ce n'est plus le moteur de
recherche qu'il faut encadrer mais les
systèmes logiciels de terminaux ce qui
montre que le sujet est bien plus large
que le seul objet de votre amendement et
qu'il faut l'appréhender à travers d'une
part la politique de concurrence
européennes mais aussi à travers une
approche beaucoup plus englobante qui
traitera aussi du sujet des logiciels
pour terminaux qu'on attrape pas avec
votre amendement est donc on est déjà en
retard on est déjà en retard par rapport
à ce que google a fait alors ça m'amène
au deuxième volet de votre amendement
qui est le régime de contrôle et de
sanction et là vous proposait de confier
à l'arcep ce rôle alors en premier lieu
moi je ne pense pas qu'il soit
souhaitable de confier un régulateur
dont la compétence est circonscrite aux
télécoms une compétence générale
je reprends vos termes de supervision
des marchés de l'économie numérique
parce que le périmètre même de ce marché
il est évolutif il est en train
d'évoluer et il est nettement au delà
des des compétences de l'arcep il est
même largement on le voit bien à travers
la compétence même de la commission sur
ces sujets
est ce que c'est la dg sectorielle qui
s'est saisie de ce sujet non c'est la
commissaire en charge de la concurrence
et donc ce n'est pas l'art simplement
levier je veux pas y cimes exposé à des
reproches vous pour dire que l'autorité
de la concurrence aurait sans doute à
voir mais très honnêtement par rapport
aux critères que vos pointes et est
d'ailleurs matériellement c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure vous qualifiez
l'effet structurant sur l'économie qui
est une notion droit de la concurrence
pas une notion du droit des télécoms de
l'arcep est donc là vous avez un
décalage parce que vous utilisez une
base juridique qui est celle du droit de
la concurrence pour fonder ensuite aux
motifs et vous demandez un régulateur
sectoriel de l'appliquer ça c'est mon
premier problème
en second lieu l'arcep se verrait alors
dotée d'un pouvoir de sanction des
moteurs de recherche
et elle tient aujourd'hui l'essentiel de
son pouvoir de sanction des télécoms du
cadre réglementaire européen qui ne les
lui donne pas et qui ne lui donnera pas
et donc je pense que ce faisant vous
avez un risque fort en plus d'avoir un
régime inopérant sur ce sujet là plus
globalement l'amendement échappe à la
logique sur laquelle se sont fondés les
différentes régulation sectorielle qui
était la construction qui permet
justement déroger à la liberté
d'entreprendre parce que c'est là qu'on
veut mettre un coin aujourd'hui qui est
l'identification au niveau européen d'un
marché pour lequel les remèdes
concurrentiel ne permettent pas
d'établir des conditions satisfaisantes
de marché et la mise en place d'un cadre
réglementaire haddock la détermination
au niveau national des remèdes et
leviers d'intervention etc santé
permettant d'assurer un encadrement
structurelles on comportementale des
entreprises en cause c'est cette base je
reprenais les textes qui justifie que
nous pouvons que nous poussons pour
construire en europe s'agissant des
plateformes numériques mais qui suppose
de continuer la démarche parle la
concurrence et qui suppose de contre de
construire cette stratégie numérique
cette feuille de route mairie qui
n'existe pas dont les bases ont été
posées par le sommet européen de
l'automne 2013
en posant le principe des plateformes
numériques des places de marché des
systèmes d'exploitation mais dont il
faut maintenant construire les éléments
de droit alors vous l'avez bien compris
je comprends et je souscris à votre
objectif mais je pense vraiment que la
méthode n'est pas la bonne pour toutes
les raisons que j'ai évoquées à la fois
parce qu'elle est défaillante et donc
concrètement ce sera inopérant ce sera
une opérant et en plus elle est en
décalage
j'ajoute à ça si maintenant on se place
du point de vue de l'opérateur que vous
voulez réguler google mais google à
travers vos finalement votre accroche
vous voudriez et c'est un peu aussi
l'objet de votre sous-amendement google
n'est pas en france et google n'a que sa
régie publicitaire
enfin n'a qu'une régie publicitaire
française et n'a même pas de moteur de
recherche en tant que tel situés en
france et donc ses dispositions à cet
égard se heurterait à ses limites et
elle se heurterait aussi au droit
européen qui ne manquera pas d'y voir
une mesure contraire aux principes de
vie prestations au sein de l'union
européenne et donc le paradoxe même
c'est qu'on serait pris à contre-pied
alors mais en moins que faire je pense
qu'il faut continuer avec vigueur le
débat que nous avons aujourd'hui montre
la sensibilité du sujet il faut le
porter et fort le porte et
médiatiquement l'accompagné montrer la
préoccupation de la haute assemblée
celle du gouvernement je veux ici
réaffirmer pour aller en ce sens est
allé plus vite
je crois honnêtement la commissaire
veste agger l'a compris elle a pris
toutes ses responsabilités sur ce
dossier depuis le début il n'était pas
totalement en revanche et comme il est
sorti hier et je dois ici lui rendre
hommage
elle a pris ses responsabilités moi dès
ma première rencontre avec elle elle
avait deux jours à son poste
elle s'est engagée à vraiment prendre en
compte nos revendications sur ce sujet
elle s'est engagée à défendre les
intérêts de nos opérateurs parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'opérateurs français et
elle a tenu ses engagements je tiens ici
à le dire il faut lui rendre hommage
et donc c'est qu'on continue à aller en
ce sens qu' on puisse éventuellement
avoir des éléments de traduction
nationale moi je suis prêt à avancer
dans la direction que vous ouvrez
aujourd'hui je pense que l'amendement ne
convient pas mais je suis prêt à ce
qu'on continue à travailler en ce sens
il ya une voix qui me semble plus solide
et qui peut être expertisés
c'est la meilleure protection des droits
des utilisateurs français est finalement
moi c'est là dessus que je voulais
conclure parce que la bonne accroche
pour réguler les opérateurs les
plateformes elle est au niveau européen
elle est au niveau européen n'a pas
là-bas n'accrochant c'est parce que les
acteurs ne sont pas là et parce qu'on
n'a pas le levier
par contre la bonne approche que nous
devons avoir pour
y compris d'ailleurs continuer à la
porter au niveau européen elle est par
les utilisateurs
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça qu'on les
attrapera parce qu'on aura même au
niveau européen un plafond de verre à
notre raisonnement qui est qu' ils sont
à mountain view ceux dont on parle
ils sont même pas à bruxelles ou à
berlin ou à londres bon et donc sur ce
sujet je pense qu'il faut qu'on avance
beaucoup plus vite beaucoup plus fort
sur le droit d'utiliser des utilisateurs
on a une base aujourd'hui qui existe
dans la loi du 17 mars 2014 relatives à
la consommation qui au chapitre 1er du
titre 1 du livre 1er du code de la
consommation
dans sa rédaction résultant de l'article
6 précisément de sa loi a inséré un
article l111 tiré cinq réglementant les
comparateurs de prix qui ont leur siège
en france
je vais pas en faire lecture mais je
vous renvoie à cet article qui nous
donne une base et sur cette voie qui
consiste non pas à réguler la plate
forme ce qui ressort comme je le dis ce
qui est du ressort de l'union européenne
revient pas sur l'argumentation que j'ai
fait mais à donner des droits aux
individus qu'ils puissent faire valoir
sur cette base moi je pense qu'il faut
qu'on avance d'abord en lançant des
contrôles ce qu'on a commencé à faire
c'est sur cette base aussi que j'ai pu
saisir l'autorité de la concurrence et
en travaillant sur une amélioration de
capvis hâtif essayer d'aller plus loin
donc moi je m'engage puisque nous aurons
l'occasion de nous revoir à la fois à
l'assemblée est ici la continuation de
ce texte mais pour essayer de voir si de
manière très concrète on peut aller plus
loin sur la partie de défense des droits
des utilisateurs mais je pense que les
voies et moyens qui sont utilisés par
votre amendement comme je les dis ne
sont pas les bonnes
en opportunités et endroit pour avancer
dans le sens que vous souhaitez voilà
l'explication que je voulais faire à
cette demande de retrait en espérant
qu'elle vous auront convaincu mais en
même temps en engageant à ce que sur la
partie droits des utilisateurs on puisse
avancer
merci monsieur le ministre chers
collègues
il est 12h 50 dates à d la séance doit
être suspendue à 13 heures j'ai eu un
certain nombre de demandes
d'explications de vote
donc où nous sommes très succinct où je
serais obligé d'interrompre au milieu de
la discussion de cet article additionnel
à 13 heures
voilà alors je commence par madame
briques qui m'a demandé la parole en
premier
monsieur le président je crois que je
veux bien prendre la parole mais le
ministre a fait des propositions il a
argumenté
je pense qu'on veut tous aboutir à
dissocier le moteur de recherche des
produits d'application c'est ça
l'objectif et il est même partagé je
pense par l'autorité de la concurrence
européenne à tf6 la commission la
commissaire européenne a repris un
dossier qui était complètement calme
miné par l'ancienne commission almunia
ne s'était pas occupé de cette affaire
était ce volontaire ou pas mais elle
elle a agi moi je pense qu' il faudrait
que madame la présidente de la
commission culture nous dise ce qu'elle
répond à l'argumentation du ministre et
aux propositions de travail parce que
l'objectif des deux grands régulateurs
européens et états unis c'est à terme
d'aboutir à la neutralité des plates
formes ce qui n'est pas le cas à l'heure
actuelle c'est clair que google écrase
la concurrence
je connais bien un secteur c'est celui
du voyage et le voyage c'est plus de la
moitié par internet
donc à partir de là comme google a son
propre service de voyages c'est le
mélange moteur de recherche etc
donc je voudrais quand même dire aussi
c'est qu'on dispose en france d'une très
belle pépite
il faut qu'elles puissent grandir c'est
un au problème et il faut qu'elle puisse
devenir un grand groupe pour demain et
dans le cadre du travail avec les
allemands il faut aussi faire en sorte
qu'on ait un champion européen parce
qu'on a pris trop de retard là dessus
c'est le sujet donc moi je voudrais
savoir ce que fait madame
la présidente parce que j'ai considéré
que son amendement c'était un signal que
la france voulait donner par rapport à
ces objectifs que nous partageons tous
mais c'est clair qu'on est dans le droit
européen il se trouve que hier soir la
commissaire vista guerre a agi pour la
première fois donc comment dire google
deux mois pour répondre
mais je pense que il ya une volonté
politique au niveau européen maintenant
de régler ce problème et c'est clair d
une volonté politique française
et c'est ce que vous vouliez dire par
votre amendement donc maintenant
j'attends de savoir ce que madame la
présidente répond au ministre mais je
visais merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur mini jeux vous avez totalement
raison de considérer que le bon niveau
d'intervention et niveau européen
c'est vrai mais que la réaction de la
commission elle est toute récente vous
savez le jugement que je porte sur
l'autorité de la concurrence tant comme
communautaire que ses déclinaisons
nationales et il est vrai que l'ancien
commissaire n'avait pas sur ce domaine
là comme sur beaucoup d'autres domaines
une vision communautaire une vision
européenne voire une vision mondiale
d'un différend inde d'un certain nombre
de sujets je peux vous dire ayant eu
l'opportunité de rencontrer le présent
jeune choeur avec le président larcher
ayant vu ensuite très récemment le
commissaire oettinger
ça fait partie des dossiers phares des
premiers dossiers de la commission
européenne
ceci étant cet amendement est
fondamentale moi j'y ai adhéré j'ai
cosigné il lance le débat j'ai bien
entendu vos réponses
mais il est bien clair que il est
terriblement important que nous
puissions récupérer la gouvernance
européenne de l'internet parce que c'est
vrai que l'europe ne peut pas être une
colonie numérique d'un certain nombre
d'opérateurs et comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure
catherine morin dessailly c'est vrai que
les algorithmes ne sont ni objectif ni
infaillible
ils sont tout simplement le bras armé
d'un certain nombre d'opérateurs
et par hasard on pas tout à fait par
hasard la plupart des opérateurs sont
précisément des opérateurs américains je
regrette que compte-tenu si vous voulez
de l'enseignement en mathématiques
fondamentales de la place de paris on
parle même de l'école de paris je puis
souligné que les chercheurs et
ingénieurs français sont
particulièrement appréciés dans le monde
informatique et donc il nous manque à
gravir un deuxième échelon
c'est dorée se réapproprier précisément
la gouvernance de l'internet
donc on verra comment on peut raisonner
sur ce sujet moi je prends note de votre
volonté de mettre votre ministère au
service de la réflexion pour trouver une
solution mais il est bien évident
qu'elle sera de dimension européenne
ok merci monsieur le président bien que
n'étant pas supporter de l'olympique de
marseille jirs et droite au but
nous allons sylla si l'amendement est
maintenue ce que nous souhaitons nous le
voterons donc c'est à dire que monsieur
ministre votre prévision d'un veau de sa
maman serait à l'unanimité voilà c'est
notre souhait alors parce qu'il a le
mérite d'abord il est pertinent
il est pertinent et c'est bien que ce
sujet arrive dans la sphère politique il
est essentiel que la sphère politique
s'empare de ces sujets ne sont reliés
l'importance de l'économique mais il a
bien été démontré ces dernières années
ces derniers mois que la problématique
des grands groupes à bousculer
considérablement l'aspect économique en
france en europe et dans le monde et que
donc le politique avec un grand p doit
s'emparer de ce sujet c'est une évidence
les américains le font les britanniques
le fond souvenez vous de ces auditions
musclée au parlement britannique avec
margaret hodge qui interrogé les
représentants de starbucks google et
compagnie ça secouer un peu
et c'était ça faisait un peu de bien
après ça ne règle pas tout le problème
est en tout cas c'est un vrai sujet et
j'ajouterais volontiers notre collègue
jean bizet vient d'ajouter un deuxième
volet avec l'aspect gouvernance de
l'internet
j'appuie tout à fait j'ajoute volontiers
un troisième volet le volet fiscal dont
on ne peut pas faire abstraction quand
même et au sein de l'europe se sont
posés des questions ces derniers temps
je pense évidemment à la fait à luc
slicks ou des res crif
sco très avantageux ont été accordés par
l'un de nos partenaires historiques de
l'union européenne à des grands groupes
dont les grands groupes de l'internet ya
de vraies questions qui se posent le
problème devient donc soit dans la
sphère politique aujourd'hui et il faut
s'en féliciter
rappelons quand même que le fabricant de
nos compagnons inséparables que son dos
nu de téléphones intelligents
aujourd'hui p 2 % d'impôts c'est une
vraie question
dire que les états qui peuvent lever
l'impôt pour défendre l'intérêt général
et développer une société un peu plus
humaine ou un peu moins inhumaine
donc c'est un vrai sujet donc cet
amendement et pertinents s'il est
maintenu nous le voterons bien
volontiers je donne ici on effectivement
sur un débat très très très importante
quand on regarde l'impact que peut avoir
la position dominante de google sur
l'économie il ya certes le problème du
moteur de recherche
mais il ya derrière tout indien c'est au
delà même au delà des applications qui
sont liés
c'est la recherche européenne dans le
domaine du numérique qui est en jeu nous
voyons tuer dans l'oeuf aujourd'hui des
pans entiers de l'innovation dans le
domaine du numérique lié à cette
position dominante
je le vouvoie sur département avec la
technopole de sophia antipolis antipolis
où nous avons les difficultés objectives
de d'école de développement des startups
dans ce domaine bien
à partir de là monsieur le ministre
votre réponse est implacable à la fois
de rigueur et de cohérence sur le
domaine du droit et vous avez posé la
question essentielle que faire parce que
nous ne pouvons pas rester en la matière
les bras ballants on constate une
évolution
je dois tu m'aimes que le sénat
américain a lancé une enquête sur
l'échec de la régulation y compris par
rapport à bout
il me paraît important que nous
puissions adoptée cependant cet
amendement au-delà de ces personnes
perfection réels qui ont était démontrée
mais que nous puissions simultanément
répondre à la demande du ministre qui
est qu'il y ait un travail qu'ils soient
effectués de façon à ce que au delà dans
cette question de la navette nous ayons
marqué déjà aujourd'hui un espace et une
volonté et qu'à travers cet acte fort
que nous produisons aujourd'hui au sénat
en tant que parlementaire je n'aime pas
beaucoup ce genre de démarche mais vu
l'importance du sujet je suis prêt à me
plier que nous puissions avoir une
réponse qui soit elle juridiquement
beaucoup mieux construites et en liaison
avec le gouvernement que nous puissions
trouver la réponse la plus adéquate et
adapté en l'état c'est ce qui m'apparaît
j'allais dire la moins mauvaise solution
par rapport à une situation extrêmement
préoccupante pour l'avenir de la
recherche européenne en matière de
numérique
monsieur le film suit le président ce
ministre oui le sujet que nous traitons
et de dimension européenne
on en est tous convaincus oui il faut
soutenir et encourager tant que faire se
peut la création d'un groupe puissant en
europe international qui puisse rétablir
une forme de concurrence loyale avec les
grands opérateurs américains
oui nous constitue nous constatons une
porte ouverte une ouverture de la
commission européenne depuis depuis hier
mais n'oublions pas et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je souhaite que vadam la
présidente de la commission la culture
maintienne son amendement
n'oublions pas que si la doctrine
européenne avance c'est parfois sous le
coup de boutoir
de nos amendements de nos résolutions de
nos ppl et que aujourd'hui même si cet
amendement est voué à cheminer à faire
progresser les choses sans aboutir
immédiatement je pense qu'il faut le
maintenir parce que c'est encore un
signal supplémentaire vers la commission
européenne merci je collombat constatons
que les états unis en plus d'activités
enfin défendre mieux leurs intérêts que
nous constatons que jusqu'à présent la
commission européenne a mis autant
d'activités et d'entrain à ouvrir nos
frontières à la concurrence des états
unis qu'elle se constitue qu'a constitué
l'europe en tant que puissance autonome
donc bon autrefois on disait quand on
veut enterrer une une question on nomme
une commission aulas ont fait du droit
il faudrait peut-être faire aussi autre
chose que du droit on n'a pas qu'un
problème de droit n'a pas qu'un problème
de technique
tout le monde l'a eu il a dit c'est un
problème politique
donc ma foi ce message qu'on envoie que
deviendra-t-il on n'en sait rien ce
message politique est une façon de dire
au commissariat aux commissaires
européens à dire à l'europe que nous en
avons assez de ce qui se passe et qu'il
faudrait peut-être agir
donc il faut le prendre il faut le
prendre comme ça et c'est une façon dire
encore une fois que il faut
véritablement agir alors est ce que
c'est la bonne méthode par la bonne
méthode mais ce message il n'est pas du
tout anodin
et puis pour une fois pour une fois
qu'on peut apporter notre concours et
soutenir la commission européenne a en
tout cas pour ce qui me concerne je ne
veux pas manquer ce plaisir merci bien
chers collègues il est 13 heures donc où
nous sommes capables dans les cinq
minutes de conclure ou alors de le le
débat sera sur cet amendement la sueur a
reporté après les questions au
gouvernement
alors madame morin desailly et après
vous soit nous votons soit
c'est reporté à cet après midi non mais
madame morin desailly me demande la
parole oui je voulais tout simplement
prendre la parole pour dire que je
maintenais cet amendement j'ai d'abord
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention la
réaction de mes collègues et leurs
points de vue j'ai conscience monsieur
le ministre que cet amendement n'est
peut-être pas parfait mais nous avons
encore du temps pour l'améliorer
ensemble d'ici là la cmb
je crois que c'est un travail collectif
d'ailleurs c'est un travail collectif au
sénat cette proposition elle n'arrive
pas par hasard
ces quatre ans de travail au sein de la
commission des affaires européennes au
sein d'une mission commune d'information
où tous les collègues de l'ensemble des
commissions et des groupes politiques
différents ont participé
toujours dans une belle unanimité quant
au diagnostic et aux propositions à
formuler bien entendu c'est au niveau
européen nous l'avons dit au sénat
depuis des années et nous savons ce
n'est pas le seul chantier d'ailleurs
amené c'est aussi une démarche offensive
de la régulation de l'écosystème
numérique pour un meilleur partage de la
valeur ajoutée en levant en jouant la
fois sur le levier de la fiscalité mais
aussi celui de la juste concurrence est
aussi exigé un régime réaliste de
protection de données personnelles le
loup bleu lobbying outre atlantique fait
qu'aujourd'hui le règlement sur les
données qui étaient sur le point
d'aboutir n'est toujours pas adopté or
les données personnelles c'est l'or noir
du numérique c'est ce qui justement
alimente la machine de guerre si je puis
dire
donc ça c'est encore un chantier
l'éducation de la formation au numérique
une politique industrielle extrêmement
puissant pour faire émerger des
champions européens tout cela nous
l'avons dit monsieur mise tout ça on
souhaite pouvoir le pouce et continuer à
travailler mais on constate aussi que
toutes ces années les procédures
européennes sont extrêmement lents
qu'est ce qui nous dit que la la les
conclusions de l'enquêté lui bien sûr la
communication des griefs combien de
temps ça va prendre encore et on connaît
aussi l'habilité du lobbying de google
auprès des autorités bruxelloises pour
tenter des négociations
endormir un petit peu les uns et les
autres autour de belles promesses et on
sait que ça échoue et donc je dis il
vaut mieux prévenir que guérir et
poussez vous poussez être un marchepied
par cet amendement c'est un marchepied
pour notre participation au débat
européen
ça me semble tout à fait essentiel et je
trouve que rester là les bras ballants
aujourd'hui qu'en tant d'entreprises
nous signalent leurs difficultés disent
carrément maintenance des moteurs de
recherche structure en droit de vie ou
de mort sur leurs propres activités
c'est au détriment bien sûr de la
liberté de commercer nos grande liberté
de l'abbé liberté de choix du du
consommateur donc je pense qu'il ya
urgence à agir dans ce domaine
alors je voulais juste répondra à 2,3
points qui ont été évoqués on me dit que
y aura un problème de constitutionnalité
par rapport à la politique européenne de
concurrence moi je note que l'article
102 du tf lui interdit l'exploitation
abusive d'une position dominante par une
entreprise jeu si le droit européen de
la concurrence ne sanctionne pas les
positions dominantes en tantale mais
seulement les abus donc c'est bien des
abus dont il ne s'agit d'une position
dominante lorsqu'une entreprise peut
mener la politique et le désir sans se
préoccuper de celle de ses concurrents
sur ce marché voilà la définition
donc on est je pense tout à fait dans la
droite ligne je ne vois pas ce qui nous
empêche à la fois de pousser des
décisions au niveau européen et inscrit
ce type de disposition dans notre droit
positif et agir au niveau national en
tout cas les acteurs de l'économie
numérique ont besoin d'un signe fort ça
a trop duré et nous sommes peut-être en
passe d'être dans une phase irréversible
si très rapidement
nous ne sommes pas capables de prendre
les mesures qui permettent d'inverser la
tendance à savoir ont construit ce
marché unique numérique pour en être les
acteurs les bénéfices y avait pas les
simples consommateurs pour l'instant
c'est ce vers quoi on veut nous
entraîner et on s'est encore une fois
que les procédures sont tellement lente
qui s'écoule tellement de temps que
pendant ce temps là ce sont des emplois
qui disparaissent sont des entreprises
qui disparaissent donc on doit bien sûr
à gérer là j'aurai encore plein de
choses à dire pour le prendre aux
arguments des uns et des autres mais je
vois leur qui tourne tout ça pour vous
dire que le travail n'est pas terminé
l'amendement de monsieur assouline
alors il est pas communautaire c'est
notre président de la commission des
affaires européennes le soul y est mais
je comprends quel est l'état d'esprit de
david assouline qui veut souligner par
l'axé un soutien fort à nos entreprises
aussi qu'il faut apporter
voilà merci monsieur le président merci
madame la présidente je vais donc passer
au vote
en mettant voit le sous-amendement 1792
avec un avis de dfa - pardon mais
vraiment une phrase monsieur assouline
ce qu'une phrase non je ne dis pas plus
qu'une phrase vous dites que vous êtes
d'accord mais que c'est pas le droit
européen
or vous avez dit pour défendre
amendement est le vôtre
et je suis d'accord avec cette démarche
quand le ministre vous dis que ce n'est
pas conforme au droit perrin le vote
vous dites il faut d'abord faire une
manifestation de volonté politique bien
donc je vous demande de faire la même
manifestation de volonté politique pour
que dans les trois parce que le paradoxe
est que si on propose les trois et qui a
aucun français ça sera la même chose
pour nous donc dans les 3 vous propose
un français c'est tout et après on verra
mais c'est la manifestation politique
qu'il faut affirmer je mets donc aux
voix le sous-amendement 1792 qui est
pour
qui est contre voix écoutée il ya doute
bon alors qui est pour nous sommes au
sous-amendement 1792 que ceux qui
veulent bien que ceux qui sont pour se
lève
nous faisons un assis debout sur le 1792
ceux qui sont pour se lève mois-là 9 à 2
france 14 14 bien que ceux qui sont
contre se lève
bon il est adopté et nous passons à
l'amendement 995 de rectifier bis de
madame la présidente mme morin dessailly
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
donc il est adopté
bien voilà pour ces débats et ce vote
dans l'hémicycle sur l'amendement sur
les moteurs de recherche dans le projet
doit croissance activité et égalité des
chances économiques le projet de loi
macro vous avez vu les sénateurs adopté
à l'unanimité
cet amendement qui prévoit de garantir
la neutralité sur internet et de
sanctionner les moteurs de recherche qui
abuseraient de leur position dominante
une sanction pouvant aller jusqu'à 10%
du chiffre d'affaires mondial du moteur
de recherche
une sanction relativement inédite un
amendement dans l'air du temps puisque
je vous le rappelle la commission
européenne a justement accusé récemment
google d'abus de position dominante
les sénateurs ont pris beaucoup de
retard dans l'examen du projet de loi
macron ils reprendront l'examen des
articles à partir du 4 mai prochain en
vue du vote solennel qui a été décalée
au 12 mai vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir cette séance et toutes les autres
en vod sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
il